shoot from the heart that's a good one i
think i actually just stopped at that
shoot from the heart i think would be
the best year i think it really doesn't
matter you know I like to take good
quality photographs I'd like to try and
have the light a certain way in the
person standard certainly even though
it's all very natural it happens very
quickly I work very quickly and work
with what I'm given I don't really pose
the people or anything I just kind of
worked with who I think that person is
but what I income the the honesty of it
is I think people like to live
vicariously I mean it's a whole idea of
this reality TV they like to live
vicariously through other people and see
other people's ideas and other people's
take on the world so whether you're
taking it with just a little digital
camera if you're actually taking
pictures that mean something to you in a
real way you actually have something to
say people will follow that blog you
know because you'll find like minded
people but by doing that I think you
know one of the things that separates me
is you know I don't shoot just all 20
year old hipsters you know I shoot old
and young and and that that brand comes
across in the variety of people I shoot
because I actually have something to say
and I can do that as opposed to saying
one thing over and over it gives me a
wider vocabulary to be able to shoot
people in a lot of different ways and a
lot of different types of people but you
always know it's one of my shots and
that's because you want to take it very
seriously and and I have a real
passionate about have a real point of
view and so I think you know that's what
someone has to do they have before just
decided I think I want to go out and
take pictures of people on the street I
think they really have to have a point
of view you know it's very important
what I don't shoot as opposed to what I
do shoot there's a lot of people in the
fashion business I've never shot so
without a real passionate point of view
I don't think there's anything you can
do because it just becomes a report on
product and there's a lot of blogs like
that like they're incredibly boring you
know just a report of what's out there
it doesn't do anything for me
well passion and a point of view number
one consistency you know you have to be
able to create a consistent voice
because if you're blogging in a real way
you know I think you have to do it very
regularly if it's not five days a week
or six days a week in a way that people
start to know when they can come see
your blog when there's going to be new
images up not always doesn't have to be
exactly the same time every day you know
it's not so bad to keep them guessing
that's so glad to have them coming back
once or twice but there has to be
consistency in the voice because you
just can't fake it five days a week so I
think that's really important I think
next generation of blogs it's going to
be just like the beginning of what
websites you know you could kind of do
it on your own and kind of have it and
it didn't look great necessarily but now
you know blogs are getting very
sophisticated and I think people are
going to have to really start to be
serious about the way the blog looks
it's you know the days I think of just
being able to steal images from all over
the place to put them on your blog and
just putting another two cents in on
somebody else's conversation it's pretty
close to over because the blog is not
going to be able to grow that way the
blog is only going to be able to grow
once you're in control of all the
content I think that's why street style
blogs have grown so quickly as you know
we're in control of the visuals we're in
control of the writing you know if
you're using a particular kind of blog
you can be more in control of the de
ponce and the graphics and everything
else
oh no you can't really do anything you
know I mean at least for me anyway
because you know it's so many different
things you know I mean it's the clothes
themselves it's the person it's I just
have to you know that's the artist you
know there's no if I wish I could say as
a marketer well you know if you're
wearing this brand and vova blog that
will make it really interesting but it's
not you know that's the artist in me you
know sometimes you meet someone and
there's just something that clicks you
know and it might be an obvious kind of
beauty or a non-obvious kind of beauty
or just something that you feel you know
I shot this woman in in Barcelona the
other day this beautiful older woman and
she you know really beautifully aged
face and very perfectly done hair and
fur coat and you know she was definitely
not typical traditional beauty but there
was just something so charming about her
and I don't think she'd end up on
anybody else's blog but you know that
that is definitely part of my vocabulary
and I'm sure she didn't get up that day
thinking what should I wear to be shot
by the sartorialist I know he's in town
but you know that's the fun of it you
know you just never know there are
people I see all the time that you would
think you know maybe be on the blog but
if I don't feel something and don't feel
them will be able to shoot it the way
that I once then it doesn't really
matter but all black is pretty boring
you're going to do all black you better
do some good proportion or texture or
something like that color pattern things
like that that actually real elements of
design are always a good look good place
to start